nous envoyés spéciaux là-bas dorothée
olliéric et alain du bas avaient assisté
à leur départ il s'appelle bira know
where à ostwald caroline gadji ils sont
les rescapés de cette sale guerre et
tous ont vu la mort de très près
blessures à la machette sur le crâne ou
les articulations les eaux explosé par
des grenades
les membres criblé de balles la liste
est longue des enfants qui ont ici en
dehors des chants des stress physique
dans le principe aux logiques absolument
énormes sont des enfants qui par exemple
est arrivé hier
elle va pas favoriser un espoir est
arrivé hier soir flinois elle parlait
pas vive des cauchemars ils ont des
visions ils veulent y mettre beaucoup de
joueurs beaucoup de chemin a recommencé
à parler quand je suis arrivé ici un
tiers des enfants avaient cessé de
parler
le mutisme complet et non seulement ils
ont il ne parle plus mais ils ont perdu
le la faculté de demander quelque chose
c'est à dire ce sont des enfants qui ne
demandent clairement jeu qui ne vont
plus à boire pour une vingtaine d'entre
eux c'est la dernière nuit à l'hôpital
de gainey avant d'être évacué vers la
france souvent ce sont les rebelles du
fpr qui les ont ramassé est accompagné à
l'hôpital mais pour sauver ses enfants
l'organisation médecins du monde a
choisi l'évacuation
on n'est pas à l'abri d'un petit cache
sait jamais et là ne travaille en
étroite collaboration dans qu'avec lui
uniquement pour la sécurité et pour le
transport l'évacuation les enfants sur
nairobi
pas facile de transporter ces gamins pas
facile non plus de laisser les autres
ici l'hôpital manque de tellement de
choses reste l'étape suivante la route
vers la capitale kigali
un voyage de près de trois heures dans
le territoire contrôlé par les rebelles
mais où les miliciens se cachent
toujours
l'évacuation s'est déroulée sans
incident malgré des tirs de mortier aux
environs de l'aéroport